[Música]
en france 24 hablamos de medio ambiente
bienvenidos a este espacio yo soy maría
clara calle en el programa de hoy
hablaremos para entender la importancia
de la resolución que se aprobó en la
asamblea de la onu para el medio
ambiente en nairobi la capital de kenia
175 naciones respaldaron el documento
que pretende terminar la contaminación
por plástico este se logró luego de la
propuesta que presentaron perú y ruanda
y la de japonés es un momento histórico
pues el pacto aspira a lograr el primer
tratado sobre el tema que sea legalmente
vinculante para todos los países
i
pero este es apenas el primer paso y es
que la resolución estableció un comité
intergubernamental de negociación que se
reunirá a partir de mediados de este año
su misión es crear un borrador del
tratado para 2024 el objetivo es reducir
la contaminación por plástico desde su
producción hasta su eliminación y
la conclusión es que eliminaremos la
contaminación plástica de nuestro medio
ambiente y eso es fundamental
es crítico sin duda esto es una decisión
muy muy importante de líder y de
decisión y esa meta es precisamente por
lo que importa tanto la resolución de la
onu pues los efectos ambientales no son
menores el programa de las naciones
unidas para el medio ambiente estima que
el plástico tiene consecuencias en lo
que llama las tres crisis planetarias
que son el cambio climático la
contaminación y la pérdida de naturaleza
y es que el organismo estima que si no
hay acciones efectivas toda la cadena de
plásticos convencionales podría ser
responsable del 15 por ciento de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
para el año 2005 esto impactaría
especialmente a los ecosistemas
acuáticos pues el 85 por ciento de los
desechos marinos son por los plásticos y
la cantidad de toneladas que se vierten
cada año a los mares y océanos podría
triplicarse para el 2040 y
cuadruplicarse para 2050
todo esto no sólo afecta a las especies
marinas que pueden enredarse en los
plásticos ahogarse o comerlos y tener
las relaciones internas sino que además
pueden transferir productos químicos
tóxicos metales y micro contaminantes en
las aguas y los sedimentos lo que
también puede impactar en la salud de
los humanos por eso es que se necesita
un tratado internacional para frenar la
contaminación por plásticos y de hecho
el programa de la onu para el medio
ambiente sostiene que la resolución es
el acuerdo multilateral ambiental más
importante desde el acuerdo de parís
para entender por qué hablamos con maría
alejandra gonzález coordinadora regional
para plásticos de wwf para américa
latina y el caribe esto fue lo que nos
explicó
bueno en la contaminación por plásticos
ha alcanzado niveles alarmantes y hoy es
considerado como un factor que
contribuirá a la sexta extinción masiva
sumado a otras problemáticas ambientales
como el cambio climático y la pérdida de
biodiversidad se espera pues que la
producción de plásticos se duplica con
creces para el 2040 este acuerdo es
histórico en la medida en que reconoce
que la problemática es de carácter
transfronterizo y que se necesita crear
este acuerdo legalmente vinculante para
detener la contaminación por plásticos
algo muy importante de este acuerdo es
que reconocer no solamente la
contaminación en los océanos sino que
también reconoce la contaminación en
otros entornos naturales y los impactos
y las acciones a través del ciclo de
vida todos los países que pertenecen a
naciones unidas acordaron esta
resolución y concretaron que van a
trabajar para poder desarrollar este
este acuerdo global y hacer frente a la
contaminación por plásticos la
resolución para frenar la contaminación
por plástico habla de que los países en
desarrollo necesitarán una asistencia
única y financiera para implementar este
tratado maría alejandra nos precisó cómo
puede darse ese apoyo la resolución
reconoce
que se deben considerar las las
condiciones y los contextos nacionales
dado pues que reconoce que los países en
desarrollo las economías en transición
necesitarán un apoyo adicional para
poder dar cumplimiento a las acciones ya
las medidas que se van a definir dentro
de la cuerpo esto es un mecanismo que
permite a esto esto es diseñar un
mecanismo dentro del acuerdo que permita
la asistencia técnica y la creación de
capacidades así como el instrumento
financiero
estos son consideraciones que tienen
varios de los acuerdos internacionales
ambientales como fue el protocolo de
montreal para las sustancias agotadoras
de la capa o zona y el acuerdo de parís
entonces en estas consideraciones son
muy importantes porque la implementación
del acuerdo que se espera a partir del
necesitará el apoyo financiero y la
transferencia tecnológica para
implementar las acciones pero no todo es
malo y también hay soluciones por
plástico una de ellas es la economía
circular maría alejandra nos explicó
cómo funciona
bueno algo que es importante tener en
cuenta es que hoy aproximadamente el 41
por ciento de los residuos plásticos se
gestionan mal se queman abiertamente se
vierten directamente o se quitan al
medio ambiente y el promedio global
indica que tan sólo el 9 por ciento de
los residuos plásticos se reciclan lo
cual no garantiza que estos no terminen
en la naturaleza de hecho tan sólo un 2%
de los plásticos logra su circularidad
es decir que cierra el ciclo de vida por
eso una de las medidas que se busca con
este con esta resolución es fomentar esa
economía circular es decir tratar de que
los plásticos permanezcan mucho más
dentro de la economía y fuera y fuera de
la naturaleza lo cual permitiría hacer
una recuperación más eficiente de los
plásticos que son desechados y que
puedan ser transformados o re
manufacturados para volverse a convertir
en productos que se puedan usar en mano
es así como hay soluciones para reducir
la contaminación por plásticos los
plásticos que producimos los humanos
hasta aquí nuestra crónica de medio
ambiente los invitamos consultar este y
más programas en france24 punto com y en
nuestro canal de youtube nos vemos
pronto
[Música]